Це перша ракета которая вдарила по
Миколаївському зоопарку це відбулось 28
лютого на 4 день войны згодом протягом 6
місяців у Миколаївській зоопарк
прилетить ще сім російських ракет дивом
ніхто не постраждає Ані працівники Ані
тварини які стали заручниками війни
Росії проти України тепер ці ракети
експонати
вирішили його зберегти як
напоминання про цю войну І щоб наші
потомки теж
відчували то що відчували ми когда
жили в цей час
страшно було
кутівники продовжували працювати І
навіть переїхали жити на роботу колектив
вирішив попри все зберегти найбільшу
колекцію тварин в Україні а це близько
чотирьох тисяч екземплярів
попри обстріли тварини потребували
догляду та уваги
Люди Да люди боялися приходили кажу
Володимир Миколайович мені страшно І так
мені теж страшно щось треба ж працювати
нікуди ж ми не побіжимо ми розсталися в
зоопарку з нашими тваринами а тому що
тварин кудись повести ми не могли
повести коли була зима морози слонів
жирафів бегемотів велику колекцію
плазунів риби
мавпи Куди Куди ви стоїте І
на чому вести і у нас була одна дорога
тільки на Одесу Все було перекрито і ми
були вже півкільці
майже тож рятувати тварин почав весь
Миколаїв був великий виклик від міщан
люди приносили нам корма і ми цими
кормами годували тварин коли люди стали
від'їжджати з Миколаєва а виїхали більше
250 тисяч людей і нам почали привозити
приносити домашніх тварин на це були
черепахи ящерицы і великі попугаї
маленькі попугаї і рибки приходить
дитина каже будь ласка ви не кролик
заберіть і плачет як ми приїдемо Ми
кролика заберемо Ну добре Давайте брали
того кролика брали шиншил тоже дуже
багато різних тварин
загалом Миколаївській зоопарк прийняв
від містян що виїжджали понад пів тисячі
тварин і лише за трьома десятками
повернулися господарі більшість колись
домашніх улюбленців й досі залишаються в
зоопарку це папуги папуги жако у нас
зараз сидять
це папуги Фішера також люди
принесли виїжджали ще була у нас багато
таких тварин як кролі шиншили були
морські свинки от економії вже багато їх
віддали на відділи вони пройшли карантин
у нас і ушли по відділам
по здоров'ю вони більш всі були здорові
хворих как бы таких не було тварин
всі більш
нормальним стані
були Поні ну вони дуже нормальному в
принципі стані так сказати ми їх
привили обробили ну
подивились їх клінічний
досмотр зробили зараз вони в нормальному
стані
вони вже вольєрах
годуються гуляють
того водопостачання для зоопарку у якому
живе близько чотирьох тисяч тварин це
могло обернутися катастрофою на Воду
привезли з Одеси із Кіровограда а дуже
помагала наша водоканал який кожен день
привозив бочки з водою Тому що вдень 10
кубів води зоопарку треба це водойми це
басейни це акваріум
треба щоб тварин не тільки не тільки
поїти ще й мити утворити і ми дуже
вдячні всім волонтерам Які
провозили воду до зоопарку А ми бочками
ведрами як під час Другої світової війни
розвозили по нашій території біля 20
гектарів і поїли цих тварин питання
з візового парку Утім на цьому
Випробування не завершилися від
масованих обстрілів РФ в Україні
почалися блекаути А над тваринами знову
нависла загроза загибелі дуже тривожно
було коли
одні сутки другий сутки в зоопарку не
було світла а для нас світло це життя
акваріуми якщо там відключити компресор
і то риба вся загине у слонів ворота
ворота роботи не електричестве якщо
немає
[музика]
відкриєш не закриєш нам дуже дуже
помогли теж волонтери із празького
зоопарку Ми отримали
безкоштовно
дизель-генератор на 80 кВт
березня
самі тривожні часи у нас родився
народився доміностичний леопард їх було
чотири в світі народжено і один у нас це
дуже рідкісна кішка А так Господи ну
мабуть більше 100 голів різних тварин за
цей за цей час народилася у зоопарку і
птахи і
[музика]
ссавці в тому числі і приймати і копитні
животик тобто они не знаю что война
Миколаївський зоопарк зміг вижити
завдяки допомозі небайдужих людей не
лише з України а й з усього світу рік
тому Віталій Топчій запустив міжнародну
акцію придбаю онлайн квиток у зоопарк
тоді вдалося зібрати десятки мільйонів
гривень на ці гроші зоопарк живе й
донині